welcome back so we're on problem number
9 and the figure above ad is equal to 1
so ad this distance right here this is
equal to 1 DC is equal to square root of
3 so this distance right here is square
root of three what is the value of Z and
they say not-it's not drawn to scale
right because clearly because this is
longer than this but it looks the same
okay so they want to know what the value
of Z is so what can we figure out well
the one thing that pops out at me is
well you know these are both right
triangles so this is going to deal with
right triangles and the first thing we
see is that these two angles are the
same so these two angles are the same
and this is a right angle well we don't
even have to know this but we
immediately know this is a 45 45 90
triangle right because the angles have
to add up to 180 two of them are the
same you could say 2x plus 90 is equal
to 180 and solve for it but what you
also know is that this is a this is a an
isosceles triangle where two sides of
the same I don't if you remember from
geometry class that if you have a
triangle like that and this angle is
equal to this angle then this side is
going to be equal to that side all right
that's just you know I forgot what the
property is called I think it's you know
just equal angles equal equal equal size
or base angles you know what whatever
you hopefully you remember that term in
geometry so if the in this case these
two angles are the base angles so if
this is 1 then this is also one this BD
is also going to be one right and this
is going to be you know whatever square
root of two or something so that now if
we look at this triangle something
interesting should pop out at you if
you're familiar with 30 60 90 triangles
this side is square root of three times
this side right what do we know about 30
60 90 triangles and you could even turn
back to page if you don't remember they
even give it to you right they even tell
you right here that if you on a 30 60 90
triangle on page 4 23 they draw it out
for you actually is if you have a 30 60
90 triangle like this
and this side is 30 and this side is X
then this side is going to be x times
the square root of three they literally
give that to you on page 4 23 and when
they give you their formulas right so
this side is 1 this side is 1 times the
square root of three so Z must be 30
degrees it's a 30 60 90 triangle if they
want if they asked you why this would
have been 60 degrees and then you know
if you wanted to know what the side
would have been would have been to just
using 30 60 90 triangles all right let's
move to number 10 hopefully that's not
too confusing if it is just review 30 60
90 triangles and look at that formula on
page on page for 23 number 10 if thirty
percent of forty percent of a positive
number okay is equal to okay so point
three thirty percent of forty percent so
point three times and I don't to use
times because that if I'm gonna use X
for the number so point three times
point for so that's thirty percent of
forty percent of a positive number so
that's X is equal to twenty percent of w
% of the same number so that equals
twenty percent twenty percent of w %
right so if it's w % then we could write
that as you know W over 100 right w %
right so if w is 50 that would be 50 /
100 or point five right times X well we
can divide both sides of this equation
by X and these cancel out and then we
just literally solve for W and actually
I didn't have to write it as a decimal I
mean thirty percent of forty percent of
something
if you can't just multiply the decimals
right what's three times four it's 12
there's two numbers behind the decimal
is 12 or 12 which is also twelve percent
right twelve percent is equal to and
then we say point two times what w-what
what number well let's say x w well I
shouldn't write W I'm going to write
this as Y and I'll tell you why because
this will give this will give w percent
as a decimal right so I'm just saying
point 3 x 0.4 is point 12 and that's the
same thing as point 2 times what well
you divide both sides by point2 you get
y is equal to point 12 / point2 and that
is equal to that is equal to 6.6 and you
could review decimals if that didn't
make a lot of sense to you so that
equals point 6 so why is point 6 or w %
is point six right so the same thing as
point six is sixty percent so the choice
is be sixty percent be that might seem a
little complicated and the tricky part
is really just making sure that you're
not you know using decimals and assuming
that that's a percent or vice versa the
important thing is we took thirty
percent and forty percent when you
multiply those two together that's the
same thing as twenty percent times w %
and I liked to put it all in decimals
you could have put it all in fractions
as well actually actually probably would
have been the easiest you would have
said you know thirty percent is three
tenths times four tenths is equal to two
tents times W over 100 right I mean I I
took a 0 you know you can set 30 over
140 over 100 like that all right and
then actually this actually would have
been easy because you could have just
taken the hundreds off of both sides you
said 30 x 40 is 20 times what and then
you would have gotten w is equal to 60
actually that's how I should have done
it but anyway hopefully I didn't confuse
you too much
okay next problem notice i do these
things in real time so the negatives is
maybe i don't give you the most optimal
solution at first but i think the
positive is that you you see how someone
you know you're not seeing just the
clean solution you're seeing how someone
the thought process that they go through
when they tackle these problems and i
think that that's actually a super
useful thing to see because you know
when you see these very polished
presentations that person did the
problem ahead of time and so they just
give you the answer but they're not
showing you a kind how they stumbled
upon the answer so i can only hope that
this is useful all right number 11 this
looks this looks exciting okay I'll
switch colors this number 11 let me draw
this thing and I have the perfect tool
to draw it see so oh no I didn't want it
like that like this like that so I'm a
big rectangle like that and they took
half of it like that it looks no no no
don't do edit I do I gotta go half my
eyes aren't workings roughly half like
that and then they take it half like
this and they take half like this what
they keep doing it like that then they
take a half like this then they take a
half like that destroying this is fun
okay I think this is what they have and
then they actually shade in that last
one so let me shade in that last 10 days
in with white but anyway in the figure
above rectangle ABCD that's the whole
thing is made up of seven
non-overlapping rectangles seven the two
smallest rectangles have the same area
so these two of the same area each of
the other rectangles have twice the area
of the smaller rectangle ok then it
looks that way the area of the shaded
rectangle is what fraction of the area
of the rectangle ABCD well let's just
chug through this
so let me find a suitable color so if
this is X oh I'm still using rectangle
tool if this is X and this is going to
be X this is 2x right if this is 2x and
this is 4x because they say that each
larger one is twice the previous right
so this is for X so this is going to be
8x right so then this is right am I
doing this right all right x-rite 8x and
then this is going to be 16 x and then
this is going to be 32 x the area of the
shaded rectangles so and then we could
just sum all of these but we also know
that this is half of the entire
rectangle right this this rectangle
right here so the entire thing is 64 X
this x 2 right because this makes up
half of the entire thing so the entire
thing is 64 X so X is going to be 1 64
of the entire rectangle there that's it
all right number 12 oh no I'm almost out
of time so I'll do number 12 in the next
video